SOT REAL FE CONSEQUENCES.M MICHO
ASUN AS TH CRAGEDY, ARAMI WANGI
Y,NGF PETITOND
LAUNDRIE DRAWN
FROM THEL MEDI
WITH ALL OF  'S ROLE, N, HE'S G
INTOL OF THICOS AS "THE WALL  J
EEYEARROD  TOPIC PUBLIORONO FIX.
AMONG THE FINDING THAT THE
L PO OC S% OF TEEN GIT BADI, IN
MAKES THEM FWOE ABOUT EMSELVESS
REPORTED SUICIDATHOUGHTS, 13
USERS TRAC DES KILL
.
THIS IEVNG ONCE U COMPREHEND TH
ENS USESAT GRAM EVERY
TH'S COMPARETH
USING FABO
THE
AGLIERE MENTAL HEALT
LO
TWANGY.
AUTHOR OF THAT GREATNOD 2 EAR TS
COP DECLINES IN
TEENS ACTUALLYANH
DEPRESSION SKYROCKETED.
AND SINCE 20N AG O DEFINEENS
AN  THE WORST ISIS IN DECADES.S.
SPEN TVIEWINFA MUENTLY
OPPOITPONTANEOUSLY
ENGAGEN  COMPARISONS
D
SYMPTOMSSIVE
W MIGHT TH
CASE RE?SINCE HER HE
MEDIS BEEN ENDLESS
DHOONDNCE ICIVE YOUNG LE
E
LOTSF FU
LOTINDWH NEVERIS WHAT WAS HAPPE.
REPORTS OFY CONDANRETI AND DY CD
LAUNDRIE AS TH WE T OF
ORRELEASED  ME
BGHHER OCD.
LA
LAUNDRIE SAI WHEN HE
CLIMBED INTO THE VAN WITH DIRTY
FEET.
>> WE WERE
MORNING. WE'VE BEEFIGHTIMORNIN .
N THE CAR FOOULDN'T HE LETOUN
E  YD?
ANPA CLOT, TTH THE MALE TE
BETO
ONE OFFICEEVALUATING THE CCU
AUGUST 30tE AS THOF A MENTAL HE
ATTORN
LAUNDRIE ALLEGEDLY RNED SEPTEMBT
S
AMPORTED
MISEPTEMBER 11th
Y REPRESENTINGHE A
STATON THA
S  THE
N THIS
WILLTHERN F  FROM LYE
T THE WHOLE AND THE DISSIDENCEH
E ACTUAL EROAD COULD NOT HAVE B
HEALTHY FOR THCOUPLE HPPH
S TO BE STHE SSOCIAL MEDIA THAT
N AND E OF US WILL
INSTAGRAM IN
O KNOWT YOINBS
O MY WEBSITE
CONCERNS ABOUT
IMPACT O
ITS POPULARITYIN N?GY REPORTER
YCSAN DIEGO
E OK I RERD "i"Y KIDS ARE GWI U
FIRST OF ALL, JEFF
IS YOUR COLLEAGU
AND URD I T TO B.
SUFFICED TO SAY, FACEBOOK AND
>> I THINKTHING THAT
PROBABLY -- WE SD PROBABLY
CONAT
H IS I DON'T
COMPANIES VETUDIED WHETHER
USERS AS MUC FIGURINT
HOW TO GET THEM TO USE.NK T.M I.
AS I NSIER
BULLETS, IS TO B O
BUT IT DOESN'T NECESRI GREATOP
DY W MNEOUREEEABLE TO CHANGE THE
ANALOGY THAT I DON'T THIRU ANYT
OUTCOMES.NDERSTW THAT
MORE PEOPLE BU, CARS
CREATE WAY MORE VALUE IN THE
D HEY ROY.
AND I THINAL MEDIA IS
LA
>> FOUNDTRTWANGY.
THK ED CAR
KIRWNLE.K AS MY TIMES ASLER ETO
SPENDS OEDIA,
THE LINGE  THIS CASE AT HAS FI
YOU KNOW, YOURG OS OF TH -
LIU LOOK AT THISYOUNLE ON THIST.
LIZE, WAIT A
E WAY  WOUGH
SOCIS
AT LEASTDI POLICE.HAT WHAT YOU'
THE KE WITAL MEDIS AT T
HOIT'S PEOPLINH
WHAT YOUR LIFE IS SUED TLOOK LI.
EWHEN YOUTEENAGER.
HAENY, HITS YOU  G